un véritable écrin coloré la boutique du
pèlerin est faite de tous les coups de
coeur de sa propriétaire chic et branché
les objets anciens ou récents ont été
choisies ou chinés avec soin par an et
pour l'installer brigitte et guillot n'a
pas choisi paris les un petit village
l'indre neuvy saint sépulchre 10 700
habitants située sur la route des
pèlerins de saint jacques de compostelle
célèbre pour sa basilique et comme elle
ne fait apparemment jamais les choses à
moitié elle a entraîné son mari serge à
ouvrir une boutique attenante aux
couleurs de neuvy une quincaillerie de
rêve dont beaucoup ont la nostalgie
produits anciens et bio s'y taillent la
part du lion
cette double ouverture n'est pas passée
inaperçue les gens du village vraiment
sont super contents d'avoir une
quincaillerie droguerie parce que c'est
face à des pannes et font plus 15
kilomètres pour acheter le moindre truc
qui est vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
monde
et si j'ouvre que pour le lancement du
vendredi au lundi on a eu un monde fou
tout le week-end et dimanche après-midi
c'était l'attraction et des gens qui
sont venus sans de saint-amand-montrond
les gens téléphoner en fait pour être
sûr que ce soit va et tout l'après midi
ça n'a pas arrêté
brigitte et serge ne sont pas les seuls
commerçants à avoir sauté le pas et
quitter paris pour changer radicalement
de vie 10 boutiques de néo ruraux se
sont ouvertes en moins de deux ans à
neuvy marjorie qui a créé il ya un an
mis l'étiquette en quittant sans regret
un poste de responsable de formation à
paris dans la fonction publique
explique moi je pense que à neuvy il ya
il y avait déjà un bon terreau avec
beaucoup de médecins
avec le collège des écoles donc
effectivement une vie de d'une commune
qui proposait déjà pas mal de services y
avait bien sûr déjà un certain nombre de
commerces en particulier les commerces
majeur qui permettent de faire vivre
déjà correctement à des commerces de
bouche etc
et effectivement depuis quelques années
bon bain le hasard du calendrier fait
que il ya eu plusieurs installations de
commerçants consécutive et évidemment
après bon ben ça crée un cercle vertueux
si on trouve tout à neuvy plus besoin
d'aller ailleurs
autour d'elle ne citons que le tabac
presse repris par une ancienne hôtesse
de l'air avec succès ou encore la
fleuriste havraise spécialiste de
plantes rares venues s'installer avec
son conjoint mais à les observer on
constate très vite que ce qui fait leur
succès c'est leur capacité à proposer
plusieurs services à leurs clients
relooking retouches repassage poids
relais colis mini mercerie pour marjorie
brigitte ouvre des chambres d'hôtes et
serge va bientôt donner des cours pour
utiliser au mieux ses produits magali
elle est là régional de ces nouveaux
commerçants mais suit la recette de la
diversification dans sa boutique atelier
elle accueille d'autres produits forment
une apprentie et savoure une
reconversion forcée
auparavant j'étais chez fait drôle donc
je fais partie des faits nouveaux qui
ont été licenciés en février jean fin
janvier début février et
ce mois j'avais fait entre temps un
contrat individuel de formation pendant
les quinze années chez fénols ce qui m'a
permis de pouvoir à avoir une activité
parallèle en maroquinerie depuis 2014
donc c'était l'occasion de sauter le pas
et de dire voilà je fais que ça que ce
que j'aime faire
voilà aujourd'hui on trouve tout à neuvy
presque célèbre pour ses vergers
conservatoires et sa société pomologique
un projet de magasin bio devrait voir le
jour prochainement sous la protection
bienveillante de la basilique